let's talk about these operations that
form the arithmetic yeah
what we're gonna do is I'm going to give
you the operations and then we're gonna
do an example for each one okay
so consider let's let's define what pair
of numbers I think each one is built on
real part imaginary part real part
imaginary part over there the imaginary
component is a pair of two complex
combination I'm desi David Zen wanna
teach if it's lumping together what is
built on real some imaginary part over
say action the imaginary component is
uniform that's that part there times
time so so the three things that we need
to know about addition subtraction
multiplication and in general and
division
I'm your modus I'm lumping together
addition subtraction but I'm separating
out like they intervene you'll see why
so addition that's the easy one addition
subtraction then each of these complex
numbers we've made and they will do with
the sum of there's my second complex
simple then each of these complex
numbers were made of the real part and
the imaginary it's actually so I have my
first complex that ranges
let's see if I want you please to brown
yeah imaginary part so there's my second
complex that one just rearranged every
search light
now how many of these turns when I look
at this right the whole point of my
writing open Sun is to show that
addition is still just gonna be still
commutator
I can still rearrange it right so you
can see if I want there's new complex
number at the end I want to work out
what's the real part rearrange so
slightly
how many of these turns are real under
the four that I've just written two of
them this guy and this guy they're real
okay so I'm just gonna bunch them out
the front here is my real pot x1 plus x2
how much have I got left
that's imaginary it's up these two terms
okay where was I
all right we gathered together the real
pot now I'm going to gather together the
imaginary part okay so I've got an eye
out the front because everything about
to right is imaginary
how much imaginary stuff do I have it's
on y1 plus y2 okay so in conclusion
maybe you want to write this is your
summary when you're adding and
subtracting complex numbers when you're
adding and subtracting here's the
summary you just treat the real part and
the imaginary parts separately just deal
with the real guys they dance together
you deal with the imagine goes that
easier and out comes your answer simple
okay so as an example our actual z1 and
z2 here Z 1 plus Z 2 2 plus 3i plus 1 -
all right ok I'm gonna deal with the
real pots best how much do I have that's
real there's just the 2 and the 1 right
so I get it
and then of a three I take away four I
again just you with that coefficient yes
so I've got - fine okay that's it that's
all there was to it yeah yep yep
the I mean yeah yeah you do because the
whole idea is that I want to identify
very clearly this is real this is okay
okay okay good so now let's talk about
multiplication okay so we'll do this in
general terms first so if I have a new
complex number Z that is the product of
two other complex numbers Z 1 times Z 2
okay again remember you that each one of
those complex numbers that are the
factors and they're real and imaginary
parts really making parts so what I'm
gonna get here is X 1 plus iy 1 there's
the first complex number and I'm gonna
multiply it by the second complex number
there you go X 2 plus iy 2 now just like
here writing the complex numbers each of
them has a binomial helps us see that
this we're just going to expand it just
like we would normally expand a pair of
binomials okay so for instance I'm going
to go this guy times both of these terms
right so I'm going to get X 1 X 2
there's the first then X 1 plus iy 2 now
by convention will write that guy out
the front indicate now this whole thing
is imaginary
so I've got plus my X 1 Y 2 you see
where I got that from right that comes
from this first term times that and
times the last bit in the end okay so
I'm just expanding that bit and now I'll
do I y1 by the other guys right so I'll
go I x2 y1 I'm just writing it in XY
alphabetical what up now mark what
happens on the end here right I've got I
y 1 x iy - so how many eyes do I get
I've got two of them right so I've got i
sweared hanging over here on the end y1
y2 alright now what I want to do this
thing this whole thing is a new complex
number right it's a new complex number
so just like over here I should be able
to write it in terms of its real bit and
it's imaginary did yes so I want to work
with this to simplify that a little bit
how much of this is real there are
obvious bits that are real
this bit is obviously real there are no
eyes hanging around in it now this guy
also has eyes because there are two of
them
by definition right being that it's the
square root of negative one when you
square it it becomes negative one minus
one right so this is also going to be
real so let me write that out the front
I've got my x1 x2 that's real but I'm
gonna take away y1 y2 because that I
squared has become negative 1 right
there's my real component and then
what's left is all the imaginary stuff
right solves slap my eye out the front
x1 y2 x2 y1 ok so generally speaking
that is the product of a pair of complex
numbers let's give it a go with these
numbers here so is n1 times n2 in my
example is +3 or
1 minus 1 so the great thing about this
is we're borrowing everything you know
about algebra and expanding binomials
you just have this extra additional rule
which is not that hard to manage to take
into account so tell them I'm gonna have
to - a hi that's the first pair plus
finish it off for me
3 I by 1/3 minus 12i squared excellent
okay now as you start to become more and
more comfortable with this you will
eventually stop writing I squared you
will get into the center oh I just read
that as negative one okay but most
likely you are not there yet so I would
commend you to ride the I squared any
like oh I know what that is that's minus
one so I've got 2 plus 12 which of
course is what imaginary component do I
have that's it okay now I'm just gonna
pause for a second and ask you this when
you add together when you add together
two real numbers you have together two
real numbers like I'm like to cluster we
can do that in terms of rithmetic we
also know exactly what that means in
terms of geometry right namely if I'm on
a number line you start at zero right
the first number means okay where's your
point of origin and the second member
means well what does the second number
me it means how far do you go in in
which direction right so firstly you're
gonna go three am I going to go to the
left to the right and two to the right
so you go one two three and that's why
you in at five okay we also know
geometrically what multiplication means
if I say two by three what that means is
I've got two lots of three which is six
they were got like a great thing
happening okay so if that is what
geometrically addition and subtraction
me for real numbers and multiplication
means for real numbers what on earth
does 3 minus I what does it have to do
with these guys and what does 14 minus
5i have to do with these guys I just
want that ID that question to just sit
unanswered in your mind for a little bit
because I want you to think about it
before I actually show you which will
haven't made this week okay just think
about what does it mean